but but
have any of you cheated before
[Music]
no no be honest no no honestly no no
i've had an open relationship
where i'm allowed to see other people is
that you know yeah
okay so it wasn't amazing you guys spoke
about it like you had a conversation
then
youtube no no no no we were we were
young we were young and
we couldn't really see each other so it
was like okay let's have an open
relationship but we had to tell the
other person if you'd like if you'd like
and you guys told each other everyone
i never told him and i fell in love with
somebody else
and this is why cheating is different
from men that's why but is that cheating
because she was in an open relationship
it wasn't technically cheating
but then i just
i was in love with two people at one
time which was really weird
and then i went with the other one which
which is fair because i feel like when
you're an open
open relationship in the back of your
head when you've agreed to that you have
like that you always acknowledge the
possibility
you can fall in
you said you love said that you said
this is me in my 20s right 21 22. yeah
this is the perfect time to do it um no
i'm kidding wait and so you didn't do
that at the olympics what are you doing
stupid take a hall pass if you make the
olympics guys
the village like everyone was just they
gave out free condoms like everyone's
just trying to [ __ ] everyone well it's a
lot of sexy people in one place and a
lot of male 1 testosterone and sexiness
in one spot i mean i'm not going down to
the shop at the end i might stick around
like gymnastics or like
like a little track and field
yeah i mean but even i feel obviously
shot put yeah but everyone's
somebody's trusting somebody's treasure
hundred pound a pound yeah
he's a lot of beholders there you go
make sure you that is actually a fact
like b isn't that either the whole
delight what you think is beautiful
because that's what i think is beautiful
of course the fact that you said you're
staying with someone that's 100 behind
you i don't think you understand 100
pound is like
but some people like but that's to you
that's not the guy you fell in love that
you knew like it's not but that's what
i'm saying people evolve like everyone
changes
into a [ __ ] yeah
so why can't i evolve to like that i
feel like she could yeah awesome do you
know okay go say it she could evolve to
like i can't evolve to like that what if
i do like see my likes and this is
changes like all the time like with diff
like the different people i date like it
they change for him you've changed like
you didn't like that at first now it's
like i love this guy so much i would
like starting like balloons like what's
wrong with that no that's just there's
nothing wrong with that it's just like
he's not healthy it's not real yeah like
like you're just like this is what girls
do and i think it's our natural instinct
because we want people to be like
included but like like come on body
positivity you're not going to be
attracted to this the guy the same 100
pounds that's just common
i don't know why as girls like we like
because you're smart yeah i know you
know that's not real like i know like
like in your life
make it make sense make it make sense
necessary yo they need your help right
now you can't even help me
on a dummy mission
don't be messing
reinforcements
is it weird to hear a girl say these
points yeah no because i'm not what her
point is i don't know mine oh yeah yeah
so i normally we're on the back end like
but you know what i never said that i
agreed with zayn when he was like we'll
leave but i thought i'd do the most to
make like to try
and like change that lifestyle right but
you're kind of switching what you said
yeah i just said to you i was like yo
you know it was ten years that deep and
they got fat and you're like yeah this
is what girls do too instead of saying
to everything that is
this
is where girls like we moved the goal
post and that's what you just what's
wrong with that well it's fine but like
like instead of just saying like like
that's what you did we moved the goal
post but i feel like that's where
compromise comes and that's what life is
saying like you meet halfway on so much
like even with friendships no no but i'm
talking i'm talking about in this
conversation so i'm saying that's not
real and instead of saying like
it can't be applied no
like it can be but you but you know what
i'm saying like we're on the same
wavelength okay i i think right because
you're you're smart i know you're smart
so i we were having the conversation we
were talking about
if you can gain a hundred pounds and
still be attracted to them and before
you were arguing that you could be and i
was saying that's not real and now
you're saying like now you're changing
it no i'm like
if we're going back to the earlier
conversation i did say yeah i can today
but i'm saying if like we're having a
conversation and i'm still unhappy like
i'm doing anything to help you yeah i
also did say out loud i was like i will
leave eventually like because we've done
everything we've had so many
conversations we've tried for so long
like it's actually unhealthy my question
was if you've been with someone to ten
years and they go over you said yeah
like you would say that you don't have
all that instinct no but this is after
we've had the conv the whole debate like
that
in the first instant i am staying that's
a fact
i agree i would say at first too i try
to work with them if you love them
because you didn't specify when you
answered that question when you asked
that 100 pounds doesn't come on in a
week it's like a fifth this like
[ __ ] life but there's a lot of
factors that come into that
like look to be fair like he might have
gone through depression [ __ ] a kid a
[ __ ] family member died like anything
is gonna be like to admit that but then
it's like on the way it's like okay
let's find some positive ways to
help the situation
and you want like if a family member
died you're depressed that you would
want your other your partner to stay
with you so why would you leave and
that's the thing is what we were i agree
with you is that i'm going to help you
uplift you try and get you to the best
place but if you're not but if you don't
want to help yourself and you're happily
at that hundred pounds my guy you've got
to go
that is it
that hundred could be like when it hits
100 that could be like i yeah but you
can't even see your own things if you've
got a hundred pounds
you can't
i don't know you're not afghanistan it's
not it's not sexy on xbox this is what
i'm saying but yeah because some people
think that's sexy yeah right so who are
we to say we're all quite slender like
yeah i think it just depends on who you
are as a person and what you're into
like for example a lot of the people
here they're quite active everyone's
into sports they all play sports so you
have that kind of like you deflect what
you like about your own self about onto
other people
it's a completely different person that
you're looking at like when you say 100
pounds like especially for a woman
because obviously we have more weight
whatever and it could be muscle but like
if you us
in titties oh 100 pounds goes on our ass
and titties
yeah i'm just saying i'm just hearing
like but what if what if
it was like a good way like 100 good
weight good weight she was she was
wearing about like
[Music]
i don't know i'm just saying so she was
like 80 pounds she's just got she's mad
skinny and then she put on a hundred
pounds and for
the goodness and greatness yeah i told
you the vision that's what i'm saying
the positions they do mean something
question do you think